what's up guys and welcome to Haris
hobbies the channel where we discussed
the latest tech news and delve into
newest tech products today we are taking
a look at why nvidia and AMD stocks are
going to be plummeting very soon in the
future up to 29% but before we begin
that make sure to subscribe to this
channel if you haven't already if you
want it to be updated with the latest
tech news related to pcs and gaming so
what's happening and why is nvidia named
these talks going to plummet well if you
haven't heard already a chinese
cryptocurrency mining harder producer
called bit main has designed a new ASIC
which is specifically designed to mind
for aetherium
there are many different
cryptocurrencies like manera and
litecoin and bitcoin but etherium is
definitely one of the most prominent
crypto currencies among the GPU miners
so as a result that's definitely going
to have a huge impact on the sales for
AMD and NVIDIA miners bring in a lot of
GPU sales for example just in 2017 alone
miners bought three million graphics
cards and buttoned 776 million dollars
in sales so as it is evident miners
bringing a lot of money for nvidia and
AMD but why would a GPU miners even
switch to a six in the first place when
GPUs are much more versatile and combine
a lot more things while Asics are just
limited to one type of cryptocurrency
well the performance of this new AC is
really promising for example this new
ASIC is supposed to be able to complete
650 mega hashes each second while only
consuming 750 watts of power to put this
in comparison a gtx 1080p TI which is
fully overclocked and is that 100% power
limit can only do 37 mega hash to the
second however it consumes 343 watts of
power as you guys can see that consumes
almost half as much power while only
producing less than 10% of the same
performance of this new basic and that
is why most people who are still wanting
to mining theorem
we'll probably switch to this new a
sickness coming up very soon but what
about price well we don't really know
anything about the price of this new
ASIC I think we can safely assume that
this new ASIC will provide much better
value for the dollar when compared with
the GPU because this is specifically
built to mind that also this new ASIC
isn't only just affecting AMD and NVIDIA
it's actually affecting aetherium itself
after his new ASIC was revealed to the
public the price of etherium habitats
all-time low in the past couple of
months that's right the price of a DVM
has dropped all the way from five
hundred and seventy five dollars all the
way to less than four hundred and fifty
dollars and that's over at one hundred
and twenty five dollar loss and over
twenty percent and this isn't just some
little dip in prices or anything this
has been consistently going and this new
ASIC has just accelerated the process
for example just 30 days ago it theorem
was worth about eight hundred seventy
dollars so as you guys can see if your
prices have almost dropped by half in
just the last 30 days furthermore just
60 days ago if Tyrion was worth three
times more than what it is worth right
now so as you guys can see this new ASIC
isn't just affecting Nvidia and AMD it's
affecting aetherium as a whole so
finally what exactly is going to happen
to AMD and NVIDIA stock prices well a
major research company called suit
katana has dramatically lowered their
price predictions for these two stocks
right now 10% of Nvidia and 20% of AMD's
sales profit comes from miners alone so
as you guys can see miners have a huge
impact on AMD and NVIDIA sales and
profit so what happened is an analyst
named Christopher Roland who is a
leading Wall Street analyst so his
predictions are very credible and
probably going to happen
this man reduced his nvidia pice
predictions from $215 all the way to
$200 and he reduces AMD price
predictions all the way from $13 to
$7.50 which is a 42 percent drop in
price so as a result huge stock price
drops for nvidia and AMD are coming up
very soon so when exactly is this new
ASIC coming out well this is predicted
to come out in the second quarter of
2018 so very soon also so doesn't mean
GPU price you are going to drop well I
don't think this is really going to
affect the GPU mining because this is
just for aetherium and plus
cryptocurrencies I is on a huge downfall
anyways so I think GPU price will go
down despite whether or not this comes
out or despite what performance it
provides so no matter what happens with
this new ASIC I do believe that GPU
prices will go down so here's the gist
of what happened a new ASIC from a
Chinese company called Bittman is coming
out very soon and it is promising huge
performance upgrades for if your
remaining so as a result a lot of demand
for GPUs are going to go down and thus
nvidia and AMD are going to lose a lot
of revenue and thus their stock prices
are going to go down as well a leading
Wall Street analysts believe that there
can be huge drops in stock prices for
Nvidia and AMD so it might be worth
considering to wait or a little longer
before investing in those companies but
despite whatever happens with this GPU
prices should go down so that's great
for gamers don't need to get GPUs for
many many months now but that's all I
have for you guys this time if you guys
enjoyed this video then make sure to
drop a like and hit that subscribe
button if you guys want to be notified
every time I post a new video also post
down a comments what you guys are
thinking about this for example do you
guys think these new a6 won't sell well
with the price of cryptocurrencies
across the board have this
systole been dropping into difficulty
just increasing constantly or do you
think money is gonna come back soon and
it is definitely worth to invest in
these doing basics
make sure to post what you guys think
because I do read all my comments and
I'm curious as to what you guys think so
make sure post your thoughts but until
next time